well the first 24 hours of the
children's book have been insane it is
the number one best seller in its
category on Amazon this is crazy I don't
even understand what's happening but
I'll try to explain it to you uh I wrote
a kids book okay here's the book think
like a detective it's just a fun book to
start introducing critical thinking
Concepts to kids what is evidence how do
we know that something's true this sort
of thing
um there's jokes in it that are more for
adults as well you will see that there
is a boy named Ronald there's a boy
named Ronald on one page
who looks a lot like a particularly uh
uh terrible former president and Ronald
lied about the number of kids at his
birthday party you get the joke okay you
get it we started making this available
yesterday on Amazon paperback and then
Kindle pre-orders all the Kindle ones
will come out on Saturday it's just the
way it works I had absolutely no idea
the way that this was going to go
and from the number of complaints I
received about the book you would think
that it would go terribly for example
someone wrote to me and said David this
is too advanced for young kids it's
really more for high school students I
don't think so it really is a kid's book
yes if you're six or seven
you're going to need to have your you
know adult or guardian or someone read
the book to you I get that and explain
it but this is not a book for high
schoolers no this is this is a book for
kids but someone said David this is too
advanced someone wrote to me and said
David the picture of the kid detective
on the front the kid should be a
minority it looks like the kid is white
so I'm not gonna buy the book oh boy
David the book should not be sold by
Amazon it should be sold by someone else
I get the Amazon stuff okay the the
reality is that we're not looking to buy
a thousand of these and then ship them
out ourselves Amazon's print on demand
is really convenient our main thing is
this show we needed convenience okay but
I'm with you someone else said David
this book is not accessible globally
because it is only in English that's
true we only wrote the book in English
I'm sorry someone else wrote it and said
David the book should not have been done
with AI illustrations even if we did use
AI illustrations as a base and then edit
them ourselves that was wrong someone
else wrote to me said David you
shouldn't have the Kindle available for
pre-order it should be available now
like the paperback it wasn't our choice
there the Amazon system requires some
lead time before the Kindle orders are
filled I'm sorry I'm sorry but we have
persevered
and this is insane the book is the
number one best seller in Amazon's
children's reference and non-fiction
section I
it is absolutely stunning to me we have
fulfill I don't know how many paperbacks
have been ordered I only know how many
have been shipped
108 paperbacks have already been shipped
and many more have been ordered
232 people
have pre-ordered the digital Kindle
version we have received orders from the
UK Germany Italy Australia Canada
um it's it's just incredible it's
incredible that all being said
I do want to go through and just show
you some amazing messages and reviews
that we got Braden wrote in with a
really good idea and said potential
children's book ban David huge fan of
the new children's book I think it's a
great idea plan on buying it however how
long do you think it will take for
Florida to ban it for woke
indoctrination I'd love to hear your
thoughts my friends I hope someone tries
to ban this book people have been
writing to me saying they're going to
gift the book to a bunch of libraries I
hope a library rejects it I hope someone
I have teachers writing to me saying
David I'm going to use this book in
class I'm going to read this book to my
students the book is not political yes
it makes fun of trump okay but it's not
a political book little kids wouldn't
even realize that it's like an adult
joke I would love it
if parents go crazy because their
teacher read this book to students in
class I would love it if a school
library and who the hell knows Tennessee
tries to ban the book I hope they try to
ban the book let's try to make it happen
I think it would be a great story okay
now some really great reviews already on
Amazon and please remember if you order
the book please review it it's so
important it's the number one thing that
determines how it will do
um okay X here's one review excellent
secular homeschooling resource I
homeschool my learning disabled son and
I'm excited for this book all students
should learn how to think I can't wait
for the author to publish books about
this subject for teens and adults
beautiful review
next review will bring tears to your
eyes
I see what you did there wonderful book
for our Future Leaders save the country
have your children learn about critical
thinking at ASAP
sir I write this as a big strong man I
have tears in my eyes with the thought
of giving this book to my children
beautiful beautiful message folks uh I
don't know how far this is going to go
it really started kind of as a goof but
it's now the best seller in its category
on Amazon you can get it on Kindle you
can get it on paperback buy copies
distribute them to libraries give them
to your kids teachers say here's
something to read
davidpackman.com book let's keep going
as we push this into more countries and
please review the book let me know what
you think Etc